hey everyone welcome to lab coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today I'm gonna
work on the infinite scrolling for the
search page and I am in my office but
I'm on my laptop today every stream
health seems seems pretty good so the
networks that works good so hopefully
everything will work out so on it was
probably unwise with me but I started a
an update on my iMac and I had I thought
plenty of time for it to finish but it's
still not finished so that's why I am
using this laptop right now but
everything looks okay
and let me get I'm just trying to get
everything in in position let's see
I have a certain set up for all my
screens so I wasn't expecting to do this
and I have a different monitors hooked
ups and I normally do to my laptop okay
looks good now
hey everyone see some of you were in the
chat also I completely forgot to
announce that I was doing this dream on
Twitter and on Instagram which I
normally do I I don't know I don't know
what I was thinking
so hopefully hopefully that won't be a
problem
I know a lot of you subscribed to the
channel so you're getting the
notifications anyway and let's let's get
started with Renato asked if this just
started it did it just started we
haven't even done any coding yet let me
switch over no that's not the screen I
want okay I'm gonna have to add another
screen here just like capture
there we are
that's the one we're seeing sorry sorry
I'm s I just if you're just coming in
I'm on a different computer than I
normally stream within my office so
that's why these it's it's a little
messed up right now actually I think I
can just change this one video capture
display capture there we go let me just
change this one I'll have to remember to
change it back when I stream from home
okay that's the right screen sorry about
that I'm gonna make this a bit bigger so
everyone can see oh goodness
yeah this is definitely different on the
sizes and stuff there we go okay it's
all in there now okay so hopefully that
size will be good for you all and you'll
be able to see I see there's some
questions already in the live chat I
will get your questions after we do a
little bit of coding so I'm gonna set
this Pomodoro timer whoops and we're
gonna do one session of coding and then
we'll take a little break and I'll get
to the questions so this is our search
page we haven't worked on this page for
a while and we we got the basic
functionality working but there's one
thing that we didn't do that we had
talked about doing and that was having
this infinite scroll feature so let's
see make sure this is still working yep
still working okay so for right now
what we get
when when we search is the category I
got I should say like the post type so
we're pulling in this data from
WordPress what we get what is
essentially the post type in WordPress
and then we get the title of that post
type and we also have made that into a
link I don't think all the links work
though we're not gonna worry about that
today what we do want to do is make sure
that once we scroll down we'll do
another search and get more results so
this is gonna be a little bit tricky let
me go to the code and show you how we're
doing what we're doing in case you you
you didn't see that that stream that was
at least a month of the other thing and
so show you how we're doing what we're
doing and then what we need to do to get
there we'll try to break it down into
small steps and then see how many we can
get through so this is something that
I've done before
on a non react project so this will be
interesting to see how how we're gonna
do this with react I don't think I have
this yep there it is I did on this page
open okay let's shut side drawer to give
us some space and if you want to follow
along with the code check out the github
repo the link is in the description and
I guess I'll just start from the top and
just give a very brief explanation of
what's going on here so we have this
utility that we've made
so that just basically is a wrapper
around the the fetch API okay so the
fetch API that's that's in the browser
and we're pulling it in as get JSON so
when you see that basically all snowing
is just using fetch to get data and
returning it to us in JSON format so now
let's go down a bit and see you know
where what kind of data we're getting so
this is what we're using to actually
make the call this is our base URL to
our WordPress installation and we can
reach the WordPress API endpoints by
going to WP j / WP / v - and then after
that we have a plug-in running in our
WordPress installation called multiple
post site which allows us to fetch data
from multiple post types so that's what
this part means now we set the per page
to 100 that means we get 100 results per
search this is the maximum that you can
get with WordPress I don't know I've
never come across a way to get more than
that so for now we're just going to
assume that that is the maximum that we
can get in one go which is not bad I
mean it ensures that there's not an
overwhelming amount of data coming in so
I can live with that for now and then we
search for a specific term and we also
have some filters right over what type
of data we want so that would be these
right so we can choose to get all the
data from from every post type or we can
just search a particular post type and
then we add some sorting
going on which really isn't gonna affect
what we're doing right now too much so
what we need to do then when we scroll
down to a certain point of the page so
let's say we've done a search and in
reality there's there are five hundred
results we're only going to display 100
of those results to the user at first
but once we scroll down to a certain
point on the page we want to grab the
next 100 results and then we scroll down
more we want to get the next 100 results
and we want that to happen in the
background you preferably in a way to
where the user may not even realize that
more data is is being fetched so they
can just scroll when it's seamless so I
mean we'll have to mess around with the
timing on that I mean I don't want to
unnecessarily fetch more so you know if
we set it to just get the data you know
let's say we scroll here maybe a little
early but you know for sure if we wait
too long then the user will have to wait
and if they're on maybe they're on a
slow connection maybe they they won't
even realize maybe it'll scroll back up
before the date even comes through they
don't realize that there's more so maybe
about here is the point where we want to
fetch new data obviously if your users
scrolling very very quickly they're
still gonna make it to the bottom before
that data you know appears but that's
that's the goal so we're gonna have to
just to kind of break this down what we
need to do first is be able to track the
position on the page and be able to call
a function when a certain position is
reached once that happens what we have
to do is just modify this fetch fetch
search term function
to be able to grab the next 100 so I I
think would think we'll just modify this
to do that I thought maybe we could just
make a whole nother function and we'll
see it depends I don't want this
function to get really huge and hard to
to think about so we'll see if it does
get like that maybe we'll break it out
separately so first things first let's
track the scroll and react so I have not
sorry I mean messages I have not done
this I think I've done this and react
yet if I have it's been a while and I
don't don't really remember okay so
we're using material UI so the first
thing I want to do is see if material UI
has any solutions for us built in before
I go elsewhere and either try to find a
package that does it or we just try to
make something on our own so let's see
scroll
now the scroll buttons you know I was
hoping that Scrolls by you know what I
remember where we've done this before
let's check out one of our previous
projects so I'm gonna go into github
here and run in laptops running a bit
slow if my main computer turns back on I
could switch over to that if this is too
slow I mean if it only takes a few
minutes then it may be worth it what was
it a resource center right yes yes or 7
ok so in this project of the resource
center let's bring this up right now
just to give you an idea of what what's
happening when we actually see that code
[Music]
I think it's yep here it is okay so if
you can see I know it's a little small
I'm you zoom in yeah so we have this
menu on the side here and as we scroll
things change it's hard to tell when I'm
zoomed up it the zoom messes up the
scroll so as we scroll it changes to
show us you know where we're at in this
site and I've messed up the scroll so
and if we click somewhere then we can
get new different to different places on
the page which yeah oh I don't know what
I did but I think all my zooming messed
this up anyway
this is we're gonna try to adapt that
we've done here to track the scroll so
let's figure out where that planning
guide that's it so we're going to here
and this is all on github it's public so
you can check that out and the fu s mark
on github organization you can get a
Resource Center check it out actually
why not just copy I'm gonna copy this
into the live chat now so you can go
right there if you click that and you
get an error then try copying and
pasting that if for some reason in the
live chat links sometimes give errors
when you try to click on them
all right so let's see this might be the
component that we created for this so we
may have to check out that as well let's
let's see great okay so we are tracking
scroll with Prague's okay
is it this yeah it's not me all right
okay so we're adding an event listener
on the component didn't melt okay
alright let's copy over a lot of this
and then we'll adjust it as needed
so first things first
I guess let's grab all of this
we zoom out Lisa familia gravitas
this is already quite a large component
at some point this would be a good
candidate for refactoring so we have a
lot going on in here all right so let's
go to the bottom here
okay so here's everything but obviously
we're gonna we're gonna change this up
is where we're not using our constructor
here so let's put this in our state that
we're already using so now we have
that's weird I know it's given us we
should be able to set that to an empty
array that's the state let's get rid of
this
[Music]
so we'll do this in a different way I
mean check my time here and I want to
about nine minutes and we want to
throttle how we do the scroll so we
don't basically whatever we're gonna do
when we track the scroll we don't want
that to happen over and over and over
again you know very quickly we want
throttle that and I believe we're
already using throttle so let me double
check you should be bringing okay we're
using debounce let's see I think we
should be able to bring in let's check
our package.json and see what we're
bringing in if we just brought in yeah
we just brought in two thumbs alright so
I guess we can bring in throttle as well
so it's the yarn think this is worried
we'll find out the second yeah that's
where ding okay so we're pulling in that
package low - is like a collection of
helpers so there are certain things that
are I don't know basic things that you
might want to do you know common things
that instead of coming up with your own
solution you know you can just pull
these things in from low - very helpful
basically both debounce I'm not gonna
get into the difference between debounce
and throttle right now but essentially
you use them for pretty much the same
purpose in that you you want to stop
some function from happening too quickly
you know too many times when it's really
unnecessary that it would happen that
many times
so it's changes righto
okay so now we will be able to use that
and we want to see how we're using
debounce
and then just hold out that same pattern
there we are
the bounced search equals okay great so
yeah yeah okay so we're just gonna say
handle scroll close double check that
even more space
yeah you know he's on stage
okay I thought that looks the same so
what's our problem down here
using this
okay that's why
okay
let's dude let's call this throttle
model scroll
well so we want to
yeah instead of calling handle scroll
yes we'll call throttle stone
alright ok so let's just think out loud
about this so what we are doing I got a
double check we already aren't using
component didn't mount somewhere but
what we are doing is when the component
mounts we're adding an event listener so
scroll event listener and on a scroll
we're calling throttle scroll so every
time there's a scroll we are every time
there is a scroll hopefully this little
squiggly line will go away uh-huh
but every time there's a scroll we're
gonna we're gonna throttle right so
we're not going to allow this function
to go up every single time there's gonna
be a delay but every time not every
single you know pixel this world but a
reasonable a lot of scrolling will occur
and then this handle scroll will be
called handle scroll then is going to
give us the position the Y position
right and that's gonna say that to state
now what we don't need here is this
active key right because that was
telling us what section we were in for
the scroll spy we don't need that so we
can remove that this part of it and
instead we're gonna right
a little to do so we remember and
instead what we want to do is say if
goal is close to bottom then search okay
so it's it for a certain amount of time
for the bottom then we're going to
search for those next 100 or next
however many is is left right if it's
less than a hundred we're obviously
going to get that lesser number
okay so haven't really tested anything
yet but logically this is working so
could still have syntax errors could
potentially even have logic errors but
that's gonna be for the next Pomodoro
session so right now for right now my
timer went off I'm gonna take a short
break and I'm gonna answer questions see
hey hey everyone is it a lot of people
saying hi I see some new names that I
haven't seen before so welcome all right
Abby shake says I want advice regarding
where to start my learning I've
completed basic JavaScript Abby shook so
are you are you then going through the
free code camp curriculum now did you
complete complete that basic JavaScript
portion are you just saying like in
general you have knowledge of the basics
of JavaScript I I mean I would if you
aren't already doing it I recommend
going through the free code camp
curriculum at free code camp gorg
Udacity also has some free online
courses that are good there's certainly
a lot of good videos on YouTube so free
code camp has great you know tutorial
videos but there are some other YouTube
channels that
have good videos as well I know learn
code Academy was a good resource it has
been a good resource for me and if
you're in if you like books learn what
does it call eloquent JavaScript so
eloquent JavaScript is a good book and
you can read that for free online and
then you don't know J S is a book series
that you can also read for free online
on github let's see Fox wanted asks are
you currently at work I am I
yeah I'm in my office at work I work at
Franciscan University that's a small
University in Ohio divya says i just see
how are you not bad not too bad how are
you doing
Roderick says learning a lot and free
coke an awesome glad to hear it
alright looks like there's some
discussion about someone's computer in
here Sergio says hello Jesse hope you're
doing fine yeah not too bad not too bad
I hope you are doing all right as well
michael says gotta go to the doctor but
I have been playing with implementing
the search with graph QL it's hard to
it's hard due to the weird URL
structures but I'm making progress plus
you can use fetch more for scrolling Oh
interesting
I like that
so anyway Michael well thanks for for
stopping by of in the stream a little
bit I hope everything's alright
and good luck good luck at the dr. Mitri
says hi it's nice to see you I'm glad to
see you in the chat too as well Dimitri
[Music]
you so says why not install the whole
lodash library you said basically
because I don't need most of what's in
low - I really don't need so I just
install the pieces that I need if it got
to the point where I was using most of
low - then it would probably be easier
just to install everything but right now
it's you know I just need two things
from there also my stomach is growling
so if you hear that I'm sorry
that is my stomach growling I guess I
need to eat
cool-kid says sir I have done
intermediate development in node.js for
back-end what more could I try out for
web apps
I mean there's a lot I mean it's kind of
like a difficult question there's
there's so many things that you could
try out if you want to get into more
like database stuff sorry about the arms
you can try like sequel base or no
sequel databases maybe try to set up
graph QL and use that if you want to get
more into front-end then you know it
should maybe check out a framework or a
library like reactor view or angular so
I guess it kind of really depends on
like what direction you want to go and
but I guess just to name a few things
those those wouldn't be a bad place to
start
Tellman asks what are the best books for
learning Python unfortunately I am not
that familiar with Python so I don't
really have any book recommendations
I've never read any Python books so if
someone else watching now has some
experience with Python in particular
with with good books for Python please
put that in the live chat now or in the
comments if you're watching this later
on okay so my timer is up as you all can
see so let's do another 25 minute
session Pomodoro session and then we
will hey cool no no errors I was afraid
that I had broken it like to the point
where we wouldn't even say anything but
I guess I haven't so that's cool yeah so
let's let's kind of try to test out what
we've been doing and really we could
probably just put a console log in here
for now I don't like to do too much
without testing first because you know
if you code a lot and then test after
it's harder to figure out where the
problem is so this is actually a bit
more than I normally do before I test
but since we copied over so much we
really didn't have a chance
test it so I'm just gonna do a
console.log and let's let's just say
scroll we're just gonna have it's a
scroll and then that way we can see so
this stage scroll y is greater than
position minus one
where's position okay we may be able to
simplify this a bit more
yeah let's get rid of this each I don't
think we need that so let's take out
these and then take out this each so I
mean this simplifying and getting rid of
any code at all in this huge component
is it's definitely a plus
alright so now we'll just say handle
school this that stage coli is gonna
equal window dot scroll why okay
wonderful
and then now say if this stage is
greater than position minus one so we
don't really want position minus one
instead what we want to get and let's
let's change this up let's say instead
of position minus 1 that would say
bottom - let's say 500 okay so maybe
like 500 pixels not really sure if
that's a reasonable amount right now but
we're just trying it out hey I see and
it's here hey Ana how's it going thanks
for watching okay so if this scroll Y is
greater than the bottom of the value of
the bottom of the screen - 500
then we're gonna console.log scroll also
the set headers we can completely get
rid of because we're not worried about
the headers anymore and handle necks I
don't think we're gonna need handle next
so let's get rid of that as well this
feels so good to get rid of code you're
not using
let's see rolls cold roll okay wonderful
we getting rid of that red line okay so
that's this is gonna be called when we
scroll and let's change our state of it
clean it up because now there's things
in state that we do not need so let's
get rid of header positions and also
active section but we do need to know
let's see we need to know what the
bottom like how tall the screen is so
how we find that out
let's see window heights let's just try
it out let's go in the dev tools console
and you see it's most definitely taking
a long time all right go on console
let's see no it's Heights Wow oh
goodness I accidentally clicked on one
of those links I suppose so that messed
things up all right expect you to
function
mother shouldn't it shouldn't be firing
[Music]
all right let's see what our problems
what like what did we even change from
the last time
i meannot all we did was just get rid of
things right
Don Xavier says try window inner heights
okay I'll try it if I can get a page to
load here
mmm
all right so something stopped here
all right let's make sure so it looks
like solo - throttle is expecting a
function so you run throttle this handle
scroll I mean that's that's the function
right let's see how we're doing it up
here I mean is it let's see
I mean maybe it's the maybe it's the
order I I guess I wouldn't have thought
it would have mattered but we are trying
to call handle scroll before we get down
there I don't think this is the problem
but it's worth a shot let's save that
little French
super s why are we using throttle and we
are using debounce - Evan relates API
calls yes so the bounce hey it works
yeah d bounces for the API calls to a
delay and then what the heck haha no log
pageviews not oh I know yes of course
log page use not too fun I copied over
if stuff that we don't even have so we
will eventually put analytics in we
don't have that setup right now so that
was our other error and then yet answer
your question to use throttle where
we're slowing down the amount of times
that we run things on scroll
okay all right cool no there's no hairs
were good all right so now what we want
to look for let's give it all this stuff
in the console we want to see a scroll
well let's see let's let's get some data
here folks we never said the value of
bottom did we no we never said that all
right let's set the value bottom so what
I'd like to do is set the value oh
that's what cuz we were testing it out
that's what happened in our heights nice
okay so that's our inner height so this
is how we can get that so let's go back
here and let's make I guess what you
know let's put it in state on skill
[Music]
window height and we'll just set it in
zero for now and then after we fetch we
reset window height actually fetch a
certain you know what I let's get the
window height on scroll so that way if I
was gonna get the window height whenever
we run this search but if the user
happens to change their screen with
which most users don't do that right I
mean developers do that a lot because we
want to see that but potentially like
let's say on a phone they could go from
portrait to landscape which we
definitely change the height so then
that way like every
every time the user Scrolls it will get
the height again so I don't think
that'll be too difficult performance
wise if we notice there's some weirdness
going on then you know we could always
rethink that you know at this point
we're just trying to get it to work we
can always optimize later if necessary
area okay so this stage yeah so let's
just grab this
let's see I believe these sectors
and we call this window no window
Heights windows got Heights okay
you can do that right can I set two
different things in state and the same
set state thing I'll find out in a
second okay so since we're getting
window.i now we're not gonna say bought
on right we're gonna say window this
state window heights probably structure
some of this we don't have to keep going
this state but that can happen
why don't we refactor okay so let's let
me make sure this is all loaded by
refreshing
okay this looks almost refresh area
so
search do search first here we are we
get a scroll
okay maybe five hundred isn't the best
Oh Morton says I think you missed a
window I did window window heights there
we are
[Music]
let's make sure okay all right yeah we
have to correct
hi
yes I'm not acting the same I'm gonna
have to do refresh again I need to keep
doing these refreshes because they take
forever but that's just this laptop is
slow
how many said hey Jessie how's it going
not too bad how you doing thanks for
joining us in the live chat
all right
okay that makes more sense okay yeah so
you see we're not getting I don't know
if you can see what's in the console
over there I know it's getting blocked
partially by my face so we don't
actually get the console loved of the
word scroll until we get closer to the
bottom bottom of the page so that is
working just a few observations here of
problems that we might have is it's it's
working but it's calling that like every
single time we stop scrolling like below
that point so that's not what we want
because we then we be making a ton of
API calls to fetch the same data so
that's no good I handle this let me
check my time oh five minutes I don't
have time to do this so what what I
think I'm gonna do for that particular
issue is I want to go back to a project
I did over a year ago maybe two years
ago where I implemented some of this
just using javascript jquery i want to
see how i handled that issue and see if
it can be easily adapted to our
situation because i was using the word
press api and i need to go back there
and look at at what the correct syntax
is for getting the next set of data
anyway so i I don't have time right now
in this Pomodoro session I don't really
want to do a lot research during the
stream so that's going to be something
that I look up and then maybe we'll
finish on the next stream or maybe I'll
just go
what what I did to make that work on the
next screen but for now I just keep
accidentally clicking things I hope I
didn't make the link stretch like all
the way across the page and then
vertically
oh well I'll check that out later so if
the scroll is close to the bottom in
search so what we would want to do is it
would be a little bit of a different
type of search right because where we're
going to search the same terms that we
just had so the search term is actually
saved in state so that's good
so we're just gonna call fetch search
term or it Act we're gonna call D
bounced search right I guess we don't
have to a week we could probably call
fetch search term directly either way it
doesn't matter we're gonna call that and
then it's automatically gonna be able to
get that search term well then what's
gonna need to happen is there needs to
be some sort of check maybe just a
simple if statement or a ternary or
something like that that's gonna say
we'll probably add something else to
state here like
scroll search it's just safe for now I'm
just kind of thinking of what we'll need
let's say like scroll search false would
be default but then once it flips to
true then we know that the the search is
going to be we're going to need the next
set of values so perhaps maybe this old
result count would start at zero and
then we would keep track of how many
results we've already had okay so this
this may change when I'm gonna go back
and check my old code I really don't
want to reinvent the wheel I remember
spending a lot of time on making this
work and I I it still works I mean it
was it's kind of spaghetti code jQuery
but it's been working for at least a
year I think at this point more than a
year so I know it works so I'm gonna
grab that but we're definitely going to
need some way to keep track of like
where we're at so we know what to search
for next and then we also need to know
when this runs this function needs to
know like okay am I just gonna do my
normal search or like what am I gonna
need and so I mean that it may be as
simple as just adding on another value
here and if you know we can make that
value instead of a true/false it could
just be the value so it could be an
empty string if there's nothing or you
know it could actually have something in
there if we are gonna do the scroll
search so maybe able to simplify that a
bit I think my time is about to be up
yeah eight seconds
all right so I'm going to go back to the
live chat I'm going to answer some
questions so in each scroll
the bed
okay so we have a question from pool kit
it says I have tried out some libraries
and frameworks like react so in general
some example of projects I could start
out with okay so you'd like example
frogs eggs if I were you and just wanted
some example projects check out free
code Kent org and go to some of their
projects and try to build those projects
in whatever framework you want see if
you were testing different frameworks
you could say like for instance the
weather app project and you could try to
build a weather app and view and build
it and react and build it in angular
it's a simple enough project that you
know wouldn't take all your time to
build those three apps different ones
just to get a feel for them or just
practice with whatever framework and you
can certainly build it without any
framework at all but that's where I
checked for projects because the the
project ideas are there but then it's
also like pretty detailed like these are
the user stories that need to be
fulfilled so if if you're kind of just
looking for guidance for practice that's
that's very helpful
yo-yo Lu Kiran sorry if I'm
mispronouncing that please let me know
how to pronounce it but you look here
and says I'm new to react but I can't
understand state and props and being
confused okay let's go over state and
props a little bit then so the this this
component does have states so I guess
we'll start here it may be a bit complex
but state for a component they're just
basically variables that we're saving to
that component that could change based
on I mean pretty much like anything that
could happen on a page user interactions
or you know whatever type of event is
going to
that can be tracked on a page could
potentially be you know part of state
state could even have data at it like
we're doing here so state changes in
response to getting new data now the
cool thing about state and react is that
anytime state changes it rear Enders the
component so we don't have to worry like
for instance if we are using vanilla
JavaScript or jQuery or something and
like let's say we make an API call we
get back data then we have to insert
that data into the page so we have to
you know have some way to like okay
let's wait for the data and then now
lets you know select where we want that
data to go and insert it into the page
so with react we don't worry about that
you know we just say if the data is
there then render it out if it's not
there don't do anything and every single
time something in state changed it's
just gonna check and it's gonna say okay
do we have data no all right cool oh we
do have data all right let's put it on
the page so that's that's where state
comes into play and react as opposed to
props props are basically values that
you pass down to a component and so
let's let's find a good example of props
I'd like to find somewhere that would be
a little bit more simple maybe in the
drawer see if we have something right on
okay yeah okay so in this this is a
parent component called drawer Jas and
we're passing down props right so we've
created all these props so one of them
is toggle drawer so we're actually
passing down this value this toggle
drawer value and I believe yeah that's
actually a func so we're passing down a
function
as a prop which is really cool so it can
be used by this child component we're
passing down expand item as well we're
passing down an ID we're and in this
case we're just passing down a string
just a regular string we're passing down
text all right and we're passing down
some data race we're passing down this
admissions menu which is just an array
of objects and then we're passing down
the value for is open and this is going
to be a boolean to true or false
so let's go into draw item and see what
can change based on these so in draw
item you know we have all these props
and let's see what what happens so if
you see we can use expand items so for
this list item on click it calls expand
item which has been passed on so it'll
reach up the component chain to the
parent component that actually has that
function and it will run right and it
will change the state of that parent
component and then that that state will
be passed down and eventually change
change what's happening so we'll know
whether or not like for instance this
collapsible menu it will change the
state of is open right once we click on
that from false to true now this
collapse collapsible list will be open
you can see also that primary text that
we saw we passed in is props this is
getting passed down to props to another
component and that's going to determine
the actual text that users see for that
component the value of the prop is open
whether it's true or false is also going
to determine on which of these
components actually even gets rendered
all right so these are I guess I could I
could show you so the components that
we've been dealing with here are these
ones here so this is the state that's
happening whether or not this is open or
closed and which icon gets rendered all
right and we have other examples here so
that toggle drawer the toggle drawer
function actually toggles whether or not
that side drawer is open or closed I
mean that's that's a lot of examples so
I don't want to get too confusing with
all of this but that's basically it so
if you want to give about you to a
component when you're using that
component right that's a prop you pass
in a property okay if you want own it to
be able to rerender based on something
based on some value then you use state
when you do you state never change it
directly always use set state so you're
gonna use this set state if you don't
use this set state react will not know
that state has changed and so you won't
get that rerender and there'll be a
discrepancy and so you you don't want
that to happen so always use this set
state to change state it's if you've
come from trying to build something with
the vanilla JavaScript or jQuery and
manage state like manually and then
coming to react you can really
appreciate just how nice it is to have
things like taken care of like that and
very organized so I'm not sure if that
was a great introduction to
date and props I'm sure I'm missing
things so help me out in the live chat
if I've missed something or if I said
something wrong but hopefully that tenet
maybe put you on the right track to
understanding state and props a bit more
how Dmitri says Jessie I see you were a
little tired yeah I had hard time
falling asleep last night so I even took
like melatonin supposed to help you
sleep and I still had trouble falling
asleep so I didn't get my normal amount
of sleep I didn't get to exercise this
morning so yeah just a little tired I
didn't I didn't get the breakfast so
there's like all these things happen
that contributed to my probably looking
really tired right now and feeling tired
yeah so hopefully I can get to bed at a
decent hour tonight
supera said is this project open source
it sure is
yeah so just check out the link in the
github repo feel free to use any of the
code however you want I also really
enjoy it if you all have advice open up
an issue or if you want to open a pull
request I'd be happy to work with you
especially if you're new and really want
to get your first pull request in and
you know let me know I'll I'll help you
find something to work on you know check
out the open issues already and I can
help work you through that process I
know it's pretty intimidating submitting
your first pull request so I'd like to
help you through that you know maybe if
you submit a pull request or - even if
it's small then you can gotta get used
to the flow of it gain some confidence
and you'll go out and work on you know
some open source project that you would
really like to be a part of see
Monkeyman says I'm still learning HTML
well good for you keep up with it you
you get through HTML and you'll get into
CSS and JavaScript before you know it
mimesis what are those warnings when I
upgraded to a newer version of material
UI some of some things the way things
were names changed and so I'm getting
warnings about that so I just need to
switch over to the newer way of naming
things and then that'll get rid of the
warnings so that's why I'm not that
worried about it right now I know what
they are and I know how to fix it I just
haven't gotten a
to doing it so that's actually something
I believe there's an issue open for that
now so that's something that would be
helpful if someone wanted to submit a
pull request for that otherwise I mean
now I'll get around to fixing it at some
point there's probably a newer version
of material out that I need to upgrade
to anyway it seems like they update very
frequently which is great I love that
Raul says Jessie I have a major problem
my websites mobile version is
redirecting in to some other websites
whoa roll says you know how to make it
alright again please help yeah I mean I
I would definitely have to see the
website so I don't know if you want to
you may not want to send details about
it in the live chat here you send me a
DM on Twitter you can find I think my
Twitter's in the description if not go
to my youtube channel the link to that
is in the description and I think my
Twitter's linked from there I think it's
just Jesse ry Google is my twitter
handle but send me a DM or something
with the info because I really have no
idea without without seeing more the
details let's see John Kane says I lost
my place
John Kane says are you using a subdomain
for mobile or just media queries ok so
it looks like John's trying to help out
roll with with the issue Carlos says
what framework are you using
ok yeah so I'm gonna skip through a bit
in this you all can check it out in the
chat in the live chat if you want but
I'm gonna I'm gonna skip through here
find some more questions
yeah I actually reading through some of
this right well yeah I think somebody
got into your site and is yeah oh
goodness
yeah yeah I mean I you have some
malicious stuff going on with your site
so that's that stuff's gonna need to be
removed
- definitely remove any plugins that you
think are causing that I've dealt with
some of the stuff with WordPress before
it can be tricky to find where all of it
is is I've dealt with things where like
that the actual anyway I target I don't
wanna say too much or the wrong thing
because till I know more the details but
yeah it's you need to get rid of all the
infected files or that's not going to
stop and you may get rid of some of it
and it will come back and that means you
you haven't really gotten like
everything so it can be a bit tricky to
find it carlos recommends sue sue curry
security scanner yeah that is that's a
good scanner i've used that before
okay John Hanson's here hey John how's
it going John says the new react didn't
derive state from props lifecycle method
could help build your component that
won't cause any page data reloads when
it calls your page scroll function that
changes a state oh okay I'll have to
check that out alright thanks for that
yeah I haven't I haven't looked at that
that lifecycle function at all at all
yet I'll check it out
Joe Joe says how to prevent from DDoS
attacks so it's a distributed denial of
service attacks I probably the easiest
way to help protect that is use like
something like CloudFlare right use a
CDN and they have a lot of built-in
protections so it won't like guarantee
that you'd be fine no matter what but
you know if you if you don't want to you
know try to become an expert at doing
your own security then I would I would
say that's you know use something like
that and you know let them handle it so
that would be my advice I mean if you
wanted to get deeper into it I'm sure
there's a lot of other things you could
do on your site but really like I just I
wonder how worth it is unless that's
something you really want to learn and
get into
Carlos says I don't think DDoS attacks
can be prevented yeah yeah for sure
that's a good point Carlos so the
original question was how to prevent
DDoS attacks yeah you can't you know
prevent the DDoS attack right somebody
can try it if they want to but what you
can do is take steps to make sure that
if it happens it won't mess up your site
too badly right it won't slow everything
down to the point where your site
becomes unusable and that's where
something like a CDN would would be
helpful
hey hard [ __ ] see also going hard [ __ ]
Mario says it's the repo for this
project final or a work in progress but
most definitely a work in progress del
toolable says I have heard services like
cloud for help prevent DDoS yeah for
sure
yeah I didn't I sorry I I didn't see
that comment first but yeah yeah for
sure they can be helpful I mean if you
don't have that and you notice you are
receiving like a DDoS attack you can
like manually go in try to check what IP
address is that this is coming from and
then block those IP addresses so like
worst case scenario and it happens and
you have no protections you can do that
it depending on how big of an attack it
is like it may or may not help it won't
hurt anything to try but it's I've done
it before and you know it it lessens the
severity depending on like how quickly
you can keep that the problem is like it
just depends right if somebody wants to
spend the money to be able to do a
really big attack it could come from a
lot of different IP addresses right but
if somebody if it's a small attack it's
only coming from a few IP addresses you
may successfully be able to block those
IP addresses and mitigate the attack so
yeah so I mean like definitely like try
to get hooked up with CloudFlare or
another
that offers some protection and then you
know if it happens then you can try to
manually like see where the trackers
coming and then block IP addresses okay
all right well I've gotten to the end of
questions so I am going to end the
stream now we did we worked through a
bit right we didn't get everything
finished but that's alright we've we've
come up with a process we have kind of
the next steps already thought out so
this will we'll do this I'm gonna save
it well I'll try to get this working if
for some reason we get stuck and it's
really taking a long time we always have
a fallback of just use having a load
more button at the bottom which is much
easier to implement because we don't
have to worry about scrolling we don't
have to worry about things going off
like multiple times so we could always
implement that I think the infinite
scroll is a little bit more convenient
to the user they don't have to click but
we have a fallback so no matter what
some sort of way to get more search
results will happen it will be
implemented so I think we'll be fine I
say that because you know we we're gonna
launch this on June 4th so we got a
really be conscious of time here and
like is this feature how long is it
going to take to implement a feature and
is it worth it you know could we do
something that is good but not great
just to get a feature in before launch
right so that's kind of what we have to
think about now so I think this falls
into that category of the infinite
searches would be awesome or the
infinite scroll will be awesome but we
do have a fallback if it starts to take
too long
Jojo says thank you thank you thank so
thank you very much you're welcome
hopefully
the advice helps you out alright so I
will see you all I'll probably be
streaming from from home tomorrow so I'm
not sure what time exactly but subscribe
to this channel and you should turn on
your notifications and you should get an
alert before I stream if you also if you
want to follow me on Twitter and/or
Instagram I do try to put up messages
letting you all know when I'm going to
stream on there as well so if you prefer
to find out through through those social
media channels you know feel feel free
to follow me there as well so until
tomorrow have a wonderful day